well what I noticed was there is a trend
of the Trad wife and I see this on like
Twitter Instagram whatever now I'd like
to start off by saying because I know
everybody's gonna say this I don't
consider myself to be the Trad right you
know because all right and I'll tell you
why because I started thinking about
this what is a traditional wife like
when it goes down to the Bare Bones it
means that family over everything family
over career family over pretty much
everything the ideal Trad wife is a
woman that wants to have as many kids as
possible and what I realized is that if
you don't get married before the age of
25 you cannot be a traditional woman